[Music]
let's go out to Houston and talk to
Kayla you got me on my knees Kayla I
know it's Lea what's up
Kayla um it's good how are you good good
what's going
on so um I really hate being a mom and
I'm having a really hard time with like
motherhood in general okay and I'm just
worried about like
um my marriage and then like the
relationship I'm going to have with my
daughter okay because I just it's just
really hard yeah Hate's a really heavy
word tell me about
that I
mean there's like nothing wrong with her
she slept well she smiles all the
time I just I mean it's just every day
it's the same song and dance
and like I really want to like it I I
sit there and I see like how happy my
husband is and how much he just loves it
and I just I just I just can't even
bring myself to even just like
it I don't know why I and I feel
terrible because I know my husband
deserves someone who wants to be there
and my daughter deserves someone who
loves her and I love my daughter but not
in the same way that my husband loves
her can I tell you I don't know if I
fully believe
that why do you think your daughter
deserves a better mom than
you I just don't feel like I'm good
enough man I mean like you're sick of
feeling this way why don't you think
you're good
enough it's just so hard yeah it's the
it's the worst it's the
worst it's the worst it makes you just
want to to curse Pinterest doesn't it
yeah and all the mommy guilt blogs that
are out
there people building accent walls with
their kids and their little slings and
making their sourdough bread like why do
you think you're so bad at
this I just see like how other people um
I don't give a crap about other people
what about
you I I don't know I just I just I'm not
I mean I remember before I had my
daughter I just
remember um just knowing I didn't want
kids I I just knew like my
limitations and I just knew like cuz how
I grew up was it's just like rough I
mean like you know it's not the perfect
life but I mean you know it is what it
is and um I just remember just being
like I don't I don't want to have a
kid because I just don't want her to I
don't want her to be like me I don't
want her to you know
grow up the same way as me and I'm I'm
trying really hard to change the things
that my my family how they raised me and
stuff and it's just been like really
hard I know because you're trying to
make changes out of
hatred you're trying to do different
things because you hate the way you
feel and you're trying to do things
different because you hate the way you
grew
up and that always feels like you're
pulling a sled uphill on
ice instead of oh my gosh dude I get to
build I get to decide what this life
looks like and I'm worth more than this
and so I'm gonna make it amazing that's
sustainable it's like going to the gym
and working out because you hate your
body you're trying to punish yourself
for looking crappy versus dude I'm going
to go to the gym cuz am worth an hour
and I want to feel
amazing one of those is going to end and
one of those is going to keep going for
forever but it sounds like you didn't
want to have a
kid because you knew how you felt all
those
years yeah I
know I mean how do I just cope it then I
feel you don't C you build something
amazing
how that's what I'm asking
you what do you want your home to look
like what do you want it to feel like
let me say it that way what do you want
it to feel
like like love okay what does that even
mean I just you know you come home and
you know there's like you just feel
loved and like nope break it down for me
be very very specific what does love
look like because here's why you're
going to keep chasing a feeling and that
feeling is never going to get there cuz
your body doesn't even know what that
feels
like I mean I guess just like everyone
I'm be I be happy is even vague itself I
don't I just want to come home and I
just want to know that everything's okay
I
guess is your husband trustworthy yeah
yeah he is is your baby healthy yeah are
y'all broke are you okay financially
yeah we're fine financially we do the
Dave Ramsey and everything are you do
you have
uh stable
work well I'm not working I'm a stay at
home mom for right now because you know
are no because you know no that's a
choice y'all made are you lonely as I'll
get
out I don't feel lonely I have my sister
comes over all the time um
no do you have a group of girlfriends
you put the kid and hand the kid to
somebody else and you get away for a
minute no I don't do that it's just
really uh I feel guilty if I do that
okay I feel like you're dying right
now choose guilt over resentment because
you're starting to resent your kid
you're starting to resent your husband
you're starting to resent your home
you're resenting your
life choose
guilt okay
he that's fair cuz I think underneath
all of this you don't like the life that
has I would say that you've created but
I don't think it was ever intentional I
think it just kept kind of
happening and when you have a kid
everything gets super real because that
kid wakes up at the same time no matter
how late you stayed up and that kid
needs to eat no matter what and that kid
God they don't stop
pooping yeah
right and then you start having
fantasies of remember
when yeah that's every day for me right
remember we had money remember we could
just have sex all the time remember we
just went
out I miss those days
man and it's okay to miss
them but the the Assumption here is is
that that was somehow better than what
you can choose to build right
now so it's essentially like changing
your mindset then no you got to I don't
I mean yes there will be some of that
but you're you can't just do that in a
vacuum you can't just sit on the couch
and just be like change mindset sucky
thing is now awesome and that's what
that's what Instagram tells you to do
just change your mindset no you got to
do
differently because I don't think you
hate your daughter I don't even think
you hate being a mom I think you hate
being a mom in the world where you have
found yourself
and quite possibly you hate the
routine quite possibly you hate feeling
like your husband's doing a better job
of this than you are quite possibly your
body is beginning to awaken little GPS
pins it put in you a long time ago that
said this isn't safe this is not
safe and your body is recognizing that
little girl and it's like here we go
she's going to be in this same crap you
are and that just gets so
exhausting I agree is that fair
yeah have you fully accepted having a
baby yet how old's this baby she's one
okay have you fully accepted I'm
in like you like this is a strange thing
to say but you can't there's nowhere to
go you're a mom yeah I know you know I
mean yeah I
know I know I you know and I feel guilty
for INS sayess but it's just like there
are days where I just really want to
walk away of course and I feel terrible
that makes you normal that makes you
normal I've been snowed in at my house I
don't know anybody who's got a better
marriage than I do I don't know anybody
who's got better kids than me I love my
kids they're a
riot and we've been snowed in for the
last like four
days I was super hyped to leave the
house today right I was really happy to
to to drive a normally a 30- minute
drive it took me over an hour and like
15 minutes I loved that drive trying to
not die on icy roads right just to get
out of the house from it that doesn't
make me a terrible dad makes me a
human somebody has you've got I will
will say this you got to stop with a
comparison
game you cuz what you're doing it's
almost pornographic you've got these
fantasies about what this thing is
supposed to look like and feel like and
it's not
real moms are allowed to just want to
scream and go running out into the
street moms are allowed to leave the
house and go hang out with their
girlfriends in fact they have to do that
or they'll go mad moms are allowed to go
back to work even part-time to go have
adult interaction
moms are allowed to not have to sit
there and listen to their sister who is
my best friend just sit there and repeat
the whole childhood crap that we both
grew up with yeah moms are allowed to be
annoyed that Dad just seems to be doing
this thing
perfectly all those things are human
what's more important than those
feelings is what am I going to do next
and have me and my husband sat down and
said all right the marriage we had is
over let's be sad for a
second
it's going to be a long time before I
jump up on our kitchen table when
nobody's here and take my shirt off
husband those days are over now at least
for the time being yeah they'll come
back soon but just for this season we
got to build a new marriage what do we
want it to look like and that's the
magic thing the the the nerd word in our
counseling world it's called
agency and your body is slowly dragging
you to the backseat of your life in a
sucky life and that's the one you got
thrown into when you were a kid
and I want you to take agency you are
driving what do we want this thing to
look
like what has to be true in my home so
that I can enjoy this extraordinary
Adventure I'm on called
motherhood and when some mom is like oh
my gosh I love every second of it you
could say hey go set yourself on fire
that's fine and
B good for you that's not me
that's not
me
okay okay is that fair here here's your
homework assignment your homework
assignment is
this your feelings are reminding you of
the way things used to be and they're
working they're doing
great guilt is reminding you of things
that happened when you were a kid and
you were not going to repeat
them neither of those things are telling
you the truth
okay yeah so when you feel a certain way
you feel like I hate all of this I feel
like I want to go running into the
street I want you to take your hand and
I want you to place it right in your
chest and I want you to Exhale really
big and say thank you body for trying to
take care of
me that makes sense and then we're gonna
go do the next right thing and the only
way you can have the next right thing is
if you and your husband get together by
yourself without baby
and you tell him all the things you've
told
me we've stumbled into a world that I
don't
love and I want to create a new marriage
now where we still have crazy
adventurous sex and we still have this
but we just have to do it at 8:30
because I'm tired right or I can't have
another human pawing at my body right
now and I know that's awful and sad
here's some things we can do for
intimacy I know you're going to be dying
over there I want you're not going I'm
not going to let you die here's what
that might look like for us in this
particular season by the way season 3
months season 6 months season's not four
years yeah okay but all of this is going
to lean back towards you've got agency
you get to decide what happens in this
next
season I'll also strongly suggest two
things number one please please please
please get with a mom's postpartum group
in your area okay I don't have
postpartum there's a
heaviness and it's good to be around
other moms and you don't feel crazy and
you don't feel like you're the only one
and you don't feel like you're the worst
mom who's ever existed and I hate this
because my daughter deserves better than
me she does not she deserves her mom
you but there's something about the
social norming of being around other
people that make you go okay I'm not
bananas what do you do and what do you
do and amongst all that wisdom you're
going to find something that works for
you
awesome and the second thing is I want
you to call a counselor I want you to
meet with somebody
because you got some bricks in your
backpack from your
childhood that's going to make
motherhood tough for you that doesn't
mean it's not going to be beautiful and
amazing it's just going to mean cool I
got to learn some new skills that I
don't have in my toolkit awesome that's
what a counselor is going to help you
do but all of these are steps towards
building your amazing
life and you've got agency you get to do
that I'm proud of you for taking the
call for making the call man it's big
time you said something things out loud
that are hard to say and I honor you
it's really really strong of
you and now the scary thing is going to
build something
new I 100% believe in you stay on the
line we're going to hook you up with
building an on anxious life and on your
past change your future and all the
couples's questions for humans decks so
you and your husband can have something
to talk about besides oh my gosh I hate
this and the baby pooped again and again
and again I'm grateful for you Cayla